you know if I used video clips I would
so open with a Morton joke going so I
don't have a particular thing that
spawned to me wanting to make this video
is just something I kind of wanted to
talk out because for some reason the
topic of a superhero fatigue has been
coming up in a fair amount of like the
podcasts and other YouTube channels that
I watch and it just got me thinking
about in general and I've talked a
little bit about this before I talked
about how just audience is getting bored
with continuity could lead to a certain
amount of fatigue if they start feeling
you know an obligation to watch all the
stuff and it just becomes more like a
chore rather than something that's fun
for them to do but there is another
thing that's sort of the broader thing
that I think can cause fatigue for
anything and isn't necessarily specific
to comics and superhero movies and
things of that nature and what that is
is mediocrity and I think in a lot of
ways that's what's biting Justice League
in the butt right now cuz the thing is
obviously Justice League is suffering
very much for the sins of the movies
that came before Man of Steel was decent
but divisive Batman V Superman I
personally really didn't like him was
even more divisive Suicide Squad was a
hot mess Wonder Woman was good but was
very much detached from everything else
to the point that it didn't really
garner a ton of goodwill for Justice
League I do think if Wonder Woman hadn't
appeared in Justice League it would have
performed even worse but that was not
gonna garner the goodwill that was lost
by the previous three movies well the
two middle ones BBS and Suicide Squad
most egregiously you know way I almost
think it might have been better for DC
and the future of Warner Brothers
adapting these into movies if Justice
League had been worse because if it was
worse you know they could just go well
fine didn't work we keep Wonder Woman
scrub everything else and we go and you
know what they might still do that but
my point being that if you
saw my Justice League review one of the
things I said was I kinda hope they
don't go with a hard reboot because this
feels like a step towards correcting it
and we don't necessarily have to just
throw everything out and start over but
the fact that it is a middle step means
that it lands in that area of mediocrity
and it's hard to get passionate about
mediocrity because passion moves things
and generates dollars way more than
apathy mediocrity breeds apathy and I
think that's where ultimately the death
of comic book movies and superhero
movies is more likely to come in and
that's mediocrity is different from pure
saturation now they have a tendency to
go hand in hand and I think it's
actually easier to point to video games
for like a quick shorthand at least for
my frame of reference because if you've
been gaming for as long as I have then
you know that sort of what the standard
template game is has changed through
different generations of gaming for a
while it was platformers you know this
sort of you run along you jump may be
issued a gun maybe you don't but
platformer basic platformer 2d
side-scrolling platformer that was the
template that you just plugged
everything into every publisher every
developer they all could make
platformers if there was a movie or TV
tie-in game to be made 99 times out of
100 it was going to be a platformer
because that was the go-to you just plug
it in that's what we do and then a
little bit later on when the when the
technology changed and everything else
the new sort of template game became the
third-person shooter and at this point I
think you could actually call it sandbox
games and in every case I think we're
hitting the point with uh with sandbox
and open-world games now or we will be
soon it's not necessarily the sheer
number but it is how many of them are
just kind of our white noise they're not
bad because in a way bad product doesn't
inherently derail a whole genre on its
own because
one of the one of the side effects of
something being bad is it throws the
good stuff into sharp relief you go man
that didn't work at all thank god we've
got this other thing that's so good but
when there's a whole bunch of stuff
that's just in the middle he's just
gonna go well that was fine okay there
was nothing really wrong with it it's
just kind of there that actually can
even diminish the good stuff because the
stuff that's just mediocre on like on
paper does a lot of the stuff that the
great thing is doing just you know not
with the same polish or panache or style
or passion but it's on on a basic level
it's doing most of the same stuff so as
you start to get bored with the mediocre
version that's doing it strictly
functionally you get bored of elements
that still exist in the good version and
you don't enjoy them there as much
anymore either
and I think it's a little bit of an odd
place with superhero in comic book
movies because usually the mediocrity
saturation comes in from again to use
the video game comparison you know your
third-party developers your shovelware
folks so usually and this happens in
movies too you have somebody does
something that's a big bold idea and it
works it takes off and it's because you
know they spend a lot of time a lot of
money a lot of talent was spent getting
this just right and then other folks
look at it say okay well we're not gonna
put that kind of talent that kind of
money that kind of time in this but
there's a basic template we could lift
that and do it cheaper and so like to do
a movie comparison you know in the wake
of Harry Potter you had a ton of young
adult adaptations and Harry Potter you
know was great and did very well but
then you had things like The Spiderwick
Chronicles and city of amber and all
these thing I can't even remember half
these things I'm pretty sure most of you
can't either
similarly in the wake of Hunger Games
you know you had Allegiance and Maze
Runner and all these other things that
they're just you know they sort of flood
in in the wake of it now the reason I
said
that superhero movies are a little bit
different is because usually all the
mediocrity is coming in from knockoffs
but in this case pretty much all of the
major you know superhero characters are
controlled by well for studios but
really just to because you've got Sony
which only has spider-man
you've got Fox who has x-men and the
Fantastic Four but then by and large
you're talking about Warner Brothers
controlling all of DC and then Disney
controlling all of Marvel that isn't
spider-man x-men and Fantastic Four so
it's not the wide open playing field
that usually creates the mediocrity
because usually you can't stop the
knockoffs from coming in and the thing
is like these superhero movies at hour
at such a level and to do them well is
so expensive that you don't really get
knockoffs largely because I think also
people realize a big part of what makes
these movies sell so well is that these
are recognizable understood names and
all of the recognizable understood names
are controlled by you know the studios I
already mentioned so for like a knockoff
studio to try and come in and do
something well they can't they don't
have access to the characters that
anybody would know so this is actually a
case where the power players are
theoretically gonna be the ones to blow
it as opposed to you know all these
little ankle-biters coming in and dilute
the market which is usually what you
would see happen I think I think part of
what got me thinking about this is I you
know thinking about which of the
superheroes sort of areas franchises etc
am I most looking forward to at this
point and and it does very mean pretty
much depends on whether or not any of
them have hit that mediocrity level or
not
so actually at the bottom for me right
now is the Marvel Netflix stuff because
I haven't loved a Marvel Netflix show a
season since Jessica Jones that's not to
say that there haven't been good
elements of them sin
then and you know certain parts or you
know God some of the casting has been
great even but I haven't loved any of
them since then they've been that was
pretty good it was pretty good and now
it's at the point where I did a whole
video about the fact that I couldn't
finish Punisher because I just I don't
care anymore
now Marvel movies I'm still all-in on I
still really love those the Marvel TV
that isn't Netflix that I I faded on a
while back and that hit that mediocrity
level for me even sooner than the
Netflix stuff did so when it comes to DC
the air over stuff I'm pretty much down
for I don't watch all those shows I
actually don't watch arrow and I'm two
seasons behind the flash but I love
Supergirl when I love ledges of tomorrow
and that thing is a whole I'm like yeah
I want this to keep going I I am
invested in this continuing and and even
the DC movies Wow I still don't have an
expectation for them to be good because
they got a lot of ground to make up for
for you know where it's been wonky I am
interested to see where they go
because they haven't hit mediocrity
because even even Batman V Superman that
was a failure but I was a fascinating
failure there's something again there's
something and I've said this in other
videos there's something oddly
energizing about something so bad it
makes you angry
where is something that just makes you
bored you know but for all the feelings
I've had about the various DC movies
boredom hasn't been one of them and like
I said Marvel and pretty much all in on
but there are there are a couple of
films that I found boring but they're
all in there all with characters that
have since bounced back like Thor 2 is
real boring thor ragnarok was not but
then that brings us to Sony and Fox now
Sony I don't really know how to gauge
right now because spider-man homecoming
had you know Marvel's direct input on it
I think the venom movie is going to be a
much better indication on whether or not
Sony's gonna start shoveling out media
mediocrity under the spider-man and
and affiliated characters label Fox now
this is kind of interesting to me as
well cuz I gotta break this up too
because Fox with their main x-men series
that I'm done I'm done with because I
found x-men apocalypse to be
aggressively mediocre like eh it wasn't
bad it wasn't awful but I was so
uninvested like to a degree that I'd
never experienced like you know I
watched I'm you know I've seen x-men The
Last Stand I've seen x-men origins
Wolverine and they were bad but they
didn't leave me apathetic they left me
thinking oh what a waste it could be
better I want them to be better do it
better
I see x-men apocalypse ago well that was
about two hours I guess and I think
that's why I like that's a big part of
why I have zero interest in in the Dark
Phoenix movie aside from my specific
reasons why I'm sure it's gonna suck
anyways but I am really interested in
all of the other stuff that Fox is doing
that isn't the main x-men series because
it's really interesting and it's you
know whether you whether it works for
you or not it's not just coasting on
mediocrity Deadpool is not coasting on
mediocrity Logan was not cozy on
mediocrity
Liege it definitely not New Mutants may
or may not work but it's not just
coasting on the template the x-men main
franchise yeah it kind of is so right
now the danger zones in terms of the
mediocrity put Sony as a maybe
depending on how venom comes out and I
say that I say that just because of
Sony's track record I mean the the
amazing spider-man franchise that that
was basically mediocrity out of the gate
nothing really especially wrong with a
couple decent elements but there was
nothing great about either of those
movies so Sony's like that's a that's a
stick and Asterix keep an eye on him
Fox they need to look the primary x-men
franchise die because all the
interesting stuff they're doing is all
the side work Marvel
was when the when the announcement first
came down that Disney was gonna do its
own streaming and that was gonna mean
ultimately that they were gonna pull
their stuff off of Netflix I found
myself wondering oh is that gonna mean
you know the end of the Marvel Netflix
shows at this point I'm kind of thinking
maybe that's a good thing you know maybe
you know we get one more season of
daredevil we get another season of
Jessica Jones maybe they'll give they'll
do another defenders for a blowout bring
everybody together but I don't need that
to keep going in perpetuity I just don't
and then with DC as I said at this point
DC is in such a hole I actively am
rooting for them to get better so again
I don't I'm not apathetic because while
Justice League is kind of mediocre
they've only just landed there after
being down in the pits before but it can
kind of root for somebody to pull
themselves out of just you know being in
a hole it's really hard to root for
somebody who's just posting and that but
ultimately I do think that that is what
will start to kill and that's what will
give genuine superhero fatigue is when
more students just start coasting and I
think I'm not sure there's an active
danger but I would think Marvel might be
in danger of that after infinity war
happens depending on how the landscape
changes for their individual franchises
and whether they start playing it more
safe and I know you know there are
people who say you're Marvel plays it
safe already and I mean I'm not here to
argue that one way or the other but I
mean I was really happy when they said
that Doctor Strange was gonna be their
last sort of traditional origin movie I
was glad because that had that had
started to become their standard
template and if they had kept at that
with every new character they introduced
that would have been their new media
aakriti but they knew enough to move
away from it so it depends on how things
shape up again after infinity war but I
also want to say that even and I do
think it's inevitable eventually you
know even people who are really good at
this even Kevin Feige oh I think it's
great at masterminding you know but
doing over Marvel is going to run out of
ideas or burn out or start to coast and
if they don't you know inject new blood
which they probably won't because they
usually don't they usually don't change
the people in charge until until they
realize what's gone wrong and by the
time the studio's realize that damage is
done
but I think eventually we will hit that
saturation of mediocrity but I don't
think that will mean that superheroes
will ever go away
because I mean look at any dead quote
unquote dead genre westerns they're
still around we don't get nearly as many
of them but at this point we tend to get
really good ones cuz if you're gonna
play in that genre you better have
something to say and at this point
people do and I think yeah well we'll
hit that point with superheroes
somewhere down the line so when people
ask me you know are you ever gonna have
superhero fatigue no I'm never gonna
write off superheroes as a thing that I
look forward to in general I might write
off specific franchises but that'll have
more to do with that franchises track
record or whether or not I care about
the source material and not to do with
the genre as a whole new genre as a
whole I know I will keep coming back I
love this stuff too much so I don't
really have a final point I'm getting to
like I said I just did I had this
thought I thought maybe I'd ramble it
out and toss it out there see what
happens so what are your thoughts on all
of this I don't even know how to sum it
up what are your thoughts whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast as well as
stitcher radio I am also 1/2 of the
punch like a girl podcast that is on the
fire and water podcast network Fire and
Water podcast comm and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]